so viele corona tote wie nie das robert
koch institut fordert schärferen
shutdown und mehr heimarbeit schutz vor
hass und hetze nach dem angriff auf das
kapitol berät der bundestag über
konsequenzen für deutschland und suche
nach dem ursprung erstmals dürfen
internationale experten in china den
ausbruch der pandemie erforschen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend ihnen ein
und ein herzliches willkommen an meiner
seite ist wieder norbert lehmann für den
sport einen schönen guten abend der von
mir
ende des jahres werden wir diese
pandemie kontrolliert haben
das sagt der chef des robert koch
instituts allerdings sagte er auch die
bisherigen anstrengungen reichten nicht
aus die bevölkerung schränke sich
aktuell deutlich weniger in ihrer
mobilität ein als im frühjahr und die
lage könne sich auch wegen mutationen
des virus weiter verschlimmern
die kurve zeigt das infektionsgeschehen
seit märz und das hohe niveau der
letzten wochen aktuell liegt die zahl
der gemeldeten neuinfektionen bei 25.000
164 binnen 24 stunden
mittlerweile haben gut 800 40.000
menschen die erste impfdosis bekommen
dass es ein prozent der bevölkerung die
zahl der korona toten ist mit 1.244 so
hoch wie nie jürgen kehl berichtet
bedrückende schwer erträgliche bilder
das krematorium in meißen in diesen
tagen überall in deutschland treibt 19
die todeszahlen nach oben aktuell bei
2,2 prozent liegt die sterberate der
korona infizierten
die mehrheit dieser toten sehr sehr
viele dieser toten finden wir leider in
pflegeheim und altenheim und diese
müssen schlichtweg besser geschützt
werden die konzepte müssen in jedem
alten und pflegeheim umgesetzt werden
weiter sehr belastet sind die
intensivstationen
aktuell werden hier etwa 5200 schwere
cupid 19 fälle gezählt
immerhin gab es nach dem feiertag nicht
den befürchteten zusätzlichen anstieg
doch die patienten werden jünger es sind
auch deutlich jüngere menschen unter 60
betroffen auf manchen intensivstation
liegt das durchschnittsalter der
patienten inzwischen bei 60 jahren gut
und schlecht das zeugnis des rk ii für
die deutschen in den winterferien
positiv der verzicht auf größere reisen
negativ der ansturm auf die ausflugs
gebiete insgesamt seien die deutschen
deutlich mobiler
als noch im frühjahr in dem harten
lockdown seit mitte dezember sehen wir
auch ein rückgang in der mobilität
aber er ist viel langsamer das heißt
irgendwo finden diese kontakte statt
trotz lockdown und das ist halt jetzt
anders als im frühjahr so viel mobilität
und kontakte gebe es noch in der
arbeitswelt bemängelt das lka home
office wo immer es geht sei das gebot
der stunde
jetzt schützt die heimarbeit die
gesundheit von uns allen
dazu brauchen wir noch mehr
verantwortungsvoller arbeitgeber
die wissenschaftler sehen viele gründe
die korona maßnahmen mindestens
beizubehalten um die fallzahlen zu
drücken
mit mehr als 600 infizierten auf 100000
einwohner liegt aktuell der kreis
saalfeld rudolstadt in thüringen
bundesweit an der spitze
und wegen der hohen corona zahlen wollen
sich bund und länder nach
zdf-informationen möglicherweise früher
treffen als geplant dabei soll es dann
um eine weitere verschärfung der
maßnahmen gehen
zurzeit liefen darüber gespräche mit den
ländern eigentlich war das treffen für
den 25 januar geplant dass die pandemie
die deutsche wirtschaftsleistung
erheblich dämpfen das war abzusehen
jetzt bringt das statistische bundesamt
die genauen zahlen
danach schrumpfte das
bruttoinlandsprodukt 2020 um fünf
prozent so stark wie nie seit der
finanzkrise 2009 für 2021 rechnen
ökonomen damit dass die wirtschaft
wieder spürbar wächst im internationalen
vergleich ging es für deutschland sogar
noch glimpflich ab alle experten setzen
jetzt auf den export mehr zu den
prognosen für 2021 erfahren sie in
unserer zdf heute auch frankreich
bekommt das infektionsgeschehen nicht in
den griff jetzt will die regierung die
maßnahmen wieder verschärfen
premierminister kast ex sagte vor
wenigen minuten dass im ganzen land die
ausgangssperre auf 18 uhr vorgezogen
wird
derzeit sind in frankreich gastronomie
theater und kinos geschlossen geschäfte
und schulen allerdings haben geöffnet
sorgen macht der regierung auch die
britische virus mutation sie ist in
mehreren französischen städten
aufgetaucht unter anderem in
fragen wir nach bei unserer frankreich
korrespondent wird christian christl
haas in paris was hat der
premierminister gesagt wie wir
frankreich die infektionszahlen senken
diese frage war natürlich das thema
heute den ganzen tag über
jetzt ist es raus wir haben schon gehört
die ausgangssperre wird ab samstag im
ganzen land vorgezogen auf 18 uhr das
heißt dann muss man zu hause seien die
geschäfte geschlossen sein
der premierminister sagte die lage sei
immer noch sehr besorgniserregend und
deshalb bräuchte es scharfe maßnahmen
deshalb soll auch sollen auch die
einreisebedingungen für bürger aus nicht
eu staaten verschärft werden man braucht
einen negativen test oft bleiben
allerdings hier in frankreich die
schulen
es soll aber massentests geben bei
schülern und bei lehrern auch um die
sogenannte englische variante des virus
in den griff zu bekommen die ja deutlich
ansteckender ist und eben auch für
kinder und schüler gefährlich werden
kann bei der ansteckung diese
ausgangssperre ab 18 uhr gilt ja schon
in den französischen hotspots mit
welchen erfahrungen zu beginn dieser
maßnahme gab es schon sehr scharfe
kritik aber es hat sich offenbar gezeigt
dass genau das die ausbreitung des virus
bremsen kann und zwar deutlich bremsen
herren das hat der premierminister und
der gesundheitsminister heute auch noch
einmal ganz klar gemacht in den regionen
in denen bereits die 18 uhr
ausgangssperre gilt sind die
neuinfektionen deutlich geringer als im
rest des landes die regierung hofft zu
einen weiteren lockdown verhindern zu
können
denn das würde die wirtschaft weiter in
die knie zwingen
aber hier wird zurzeit auch niemand
einen neuen lok dann ausschließen sollte
sich die lage weiter zuspitzen
danke nach paris christel haas war das
in die usa donald trump muss sich als
erster präsident in der us-geschichte
einem zweiten amtsenthebungsverfahren
stellen
das repräsentantenhaus stimmte am
mittwoch dafür den abgewählten
präsidenten anzuklagen wegen anstiftung
zum aufruhr
die demokraten und auch einige
republikaner machen
mitverantwortlich für den sturm auf das
kapitol in washington
acht tage ist das jetzt her dieser
historische angriff auf den sitz des
us-kongresses heute debattierte der
bundestag darüber was wir in deutschland
daraus für lehren ziehen können es waren
bilder wie diese die weltweit
fassungslosigkeit auslösten
gewaltbereite trump anhänger wüten in
der herzkammer der amerikanischen
demokratie eine eskalation die viele in
einem land wie den usa für undenkbar
gehalten hatten
was die deutsche politik daraus ableitet
dazu patricia wiedemeier erhöhte
sicherheitsvorkehrungen seit dem sturm
auf das kapitol in washington auch vor
dem berliner reichstagsgebäude
denn das was da in washington passiert
ist sei auch hier nicht auszuschließen
eine gesellschaftliche spaltung sei
nicht nur in den usa sondern auch bei
uns zu sehen so außenminister maß und
auch wir in deutschland mussten erleben
wie aus hetzerischen worten hast er
führte taten wurden in halle kassel
hanau und vor einigen wochen hier auf
den stufen des reichstages gehetzt trägt
verantwortung
ereignisse wie diese als im august
demonstrierende die barrikaden vor dem
reichstag durchbrachen und bis auf die
stufen stürmten müssten künftig
verhindert werden
die ereignisse von berlin wie von
washington waren beide das ergebnis
eines jahrelangen angriffs auf die
wahrheit eines angriffs aus fakten und
vernunft von wissenschaft und logik nur
die fdp von vergleichbaren ereignissen
nichts wissen
man sieht einen schamlos falschen sach
vergleich um mit schreckensbildern aus
den usa die deutsche bevölkerung
aufzuwiegeln gegen kritiker der
regierungspolitik das ist hass das ist
hetze
wehret den anfängen so der appell fast
einer anderen parteien
wir müssen unsere demokratie mit
maximaler wachsamkeit und mit der stärke
eines wehrhaften rechtsstaates
verteidigen
jetzt muss deutschland jetzt muss europa
bereit sein dass wir uns unterhaken es
darf doch nicht das ergebnis sein dass
sich die machthaber in peking und in
moskau auf die schenkel klopfen und sich
darüber freuen dass demokratische
freiheitliche staaten in schwierigkeiten
sind
einen schulterschluss aller demokraten
gegen die feinde der demokratie fordert
außenminister mast und sprach damit wohl
für die mehrheit der abgeordneten noch
mal zurück zur corona nach monatelangem
tauziehen lässt chinas regierung nun
doch wissenschaftler der
weltgesundheitsorganisation einreisen
ihr auftrag das corona virus zu seiner
quelle zurückverfolgen
ein anhaltspunkt wo hahn und seine tier
märkte hier soll der erreger erstmals
aufgetaucht sein
eine heikle mission china wehrt sich
dagegen am pranger zu stehen und zeigt
mit dem finger nach italien wo noch vor
den fällen in haan eine frau in mailand
infiziert gewesen sein soll wohl voller
berichtet
wie ein staatsbesuch wird die ankunft
des expertenteams der wm im chinesischen
fernsehen inszeniert
obwohl zuvor pekings machthaber die
einreise lange herausgezögert haben
denn china fürchtet als ursprungsland
des virus dazu stehen die fao warnt vor
voreiligen schuldzuweisungen
ich glaube nicht dass wir nach diesem
ersten einsatz eindeutige antworten
haben werden aber wir sind auf dem weg
dorthin
das team der wm nimmt unter anderem die
ereignisse rund um dem wildtier markt in
wohin unter die lupe es soll
materialproben untersuchen und
laborergebnisse sichten
die meisten wissenschaftler gehen davon
aus dass fledermäuse die ursprünglichen
werte der korona viren waren aber die
übertragung auf den menschen ist noch
unklar wie viele tierarten dienten bei
der übertragung auf den mensch als
zwischenwirt diese frage können wir
immer noch nicht genau beantworten
fragen die chinas führung gerne hört das
land will vergessen machen dass es den
ausbruch des virus info hand am anfang
verschwieg es verweist auf einige
forschungsergebnisse die darauf
hindeuten dass das virus in italien
zuerst ausbrach china will runter von
der anklagebank das macht die mission
der wehr so heikel
die forscher wollen wissen was passiert
ist und der rest der welt will wissen
wer schuld ist das war muti muss jetzt
erst einmal 14 tage in quarantäne
es kann wochen dauern bis erste
ergebnisse bekannt werden
zurück nach deutschland vergangenes jahr
hatte es in thüringen eine wochenlange
regierungskrise gegeben
am ende kam ministerpräsident ramelow
mit einer rot rot grünen
minderheitsregierung ins amt unter
duldung der cdu die vereinbarung eine
zusammenarbeit auf zeit und vorzeitige
neuwahl die sollte ende april
stattfinden
jetzt hat corona dem aber einen strich
durch die rechnung gemacht thüringen hat
derzeit die bundesweit höchsten zahlen
melanie haken er vor der wahl termin
soll verschoben werden das war aber
offenbar schwieriger als gedacht stunden
später als
plan traten die beteiligten gerade erst
vor die presse mit welchem ergebnis
genau also das ganze dauert die hier
fünf stunden seit 14 uhr saß man
zusammen und kam gerade raus ergebnis
nummer eins ist eben dass die
landtagswahl die geplante am 25 april
nicht stattfinden kann
aufgrund der pandemie lage und es heißt
aus vernunft und auch aus vernunft
gegenüber den bürgern das war punkt eins
was aber länger dauerte war tatsächlich
der neue wahltermin den man gemeinsam
finden musste
und der ist am ende ein kompromiss
geworden man hat sich jetzt darauf
geeinigt zusammen mit der bundestagswahl
am 26 september auch hier in thüringen
zu wählen
die spd sagte sie wollen eigentlich so
früh wie möglich einen wahltermin der
linken mit dem regierenden
ministerpräsidenten bodo ramelow wäre
eine eigene wahl sicherlich lieber
gewesen
grüne und cdu aber haben vor allem
darauf gepocht zusammen mit der
bundestagswahl zu wählen weil sie sich
dadurch natürlich auch aufwind für ihre
parteien hier in thüringen erhoffen
das ganze ist auch ein kompromiss weil
da nämlich auch das fragezeichen steht
wie reagiert die minderheitsregierung
unter rot rot grün bis dahin weiter und
so konnte man sich einigen das der
stabilitätsmechanismus der ja seit dem
letzten jahr die parteien zusammen
gehalten hat und die cdu in diesem
stabilitätsmechanismus brachte rot rot
grün die nötigen stimmen um wichtige
entscheidungen durchzubringen
und dieser stabilitätsmechanismus man
nannte ihn 20 soll jetzt fortgeführt
werden und das ist der kompromiss dafür
auch dafür hat die cdu den
bundestagswahltermin mit der am 26
september erhalten also damit ist das
jetzt erstmal vom tisch es muss aber
auch noch verfassungsrechtlich geklärt
werden das soll bis ende januar erfolgen
auf welcher grundlage dann der landtag
aufgelöst werden kann so bei lernen das
ist nicht so einfach den termin zu
verschieben vielen dank nach erfurt
melanie hug 2021 wird ein super-wahljahr
neben thüringen und der bundestagswahl
im herbst stehen noch fünf weitere
landtagswahlen an den anfang machen
baden württemberg und rheinland pfalz am
14 märz
in mainz bieten die parteien heute zum
wahlkampfauftakt durch corona ist
allerdings alles ein bisschen anders als
sonst
susanne gelhard war dabei wir mit ihr
die spd in rheinland-pfalz rechnet sich
mit ministerpräsidentin malu dreyer gute
chancen aus mit der ampel aus spd fdp
und grünen weiter zu regieren
sie ist die bei weitem populärste
politikerin des landes stehe eben für
das sozial gerechte thema ich stehe für
eine nachhaltige wirtschaft ich stehe
für eine gute bildung das sind alles
themen die mir auf den leib geschneidert
sind es wird ein einsamer wahlkampf um
die regierungsmehrheit in mainz keine
großen veranstaltungen wenig persönliche
begegnungen pandemie zeiten eben die
grünen würden wie die spd die ampel am
liebsten fortsetzen auch wenn sie
offiziell keine koalitionsaussage machen
wir setzen auf eine mobilitäts wende auf
den ausbau der erneuerbaren energien auf
artenvielfalt und auf eine solidarische
und gerechte gesellschaft die fdp muss
um den einzug in den landtag bangen
die wenig bekannte daniela schmid setzt
vor allem auf das thema wirtschaft das
ist die grundlage für alles das schafft
gute arbeitsplätze gute
ausbildungsplätze und ist auch die
grundlage für die zukunft in rheinland
pfalz christian baldauf heißt der
herausforderer von der cdu
zurzeit liegt seine partei in den
umfragen vorn so wie beim letzten mal
dieses mal will er den spitzenplatz bis
zur wahl am 14 märz halten
wir setzen vor allem auf starke bildung
auf starke wirtschaft und auf modernste
medizin wir haben im land rheinland
pfalz ein gefälle zwischen stadt und
land die afg mit michael frisch ist in
den umfragen einstellig sie wirbt mit
familie und bildung wir müssen mehr
leistung ins schulsystem bringen bei
wollen mit einer handwerks in
gewerbeschule auch das duale system
stärken für den fall verschärfter corona
einschränkungen ist man in rheinland
pfalz auch auf eine reine briefwahl in
einzelnen wahlkreisen eingestellt die
unterlagen dafür wird
bereits gedruckt noch ein abschied als
teil des duos siegfried und roy war
weltberühmt jetzt ist siegfried
fischbacher gestorben knapp acht monate
nach seinem partner roy siegfried aus
dem bayrischen rosenheim und roy aus
nordenham in niedersachsen waren das
erfolgreichste magier der welt mit
fester show in las vegas ihr besonderes
markenzeichen zaubertricks mit weißen
tigern und löwen
die raubtiere waren auch jenseits der
bühne teil ihres lebens sie lebten mit
den beiden auf ihrem anwesen in las
vegas die karriere des paares endete
2003 als ein tiger roy während eines
auftritts schwerverletzte räuber im mai
an group 19 gestorben siegfried jetzt
mit 81 jahren an krebs
und jetzt zur sportlichen sensation des
gestrigen abends norbert bayern münchen
aus dem dfb-pokal sozusagen eiskalt
erwischt im schneesturm an der ostsee
zweitligist kiel besiegte den champions
league sieger nach elfmeterschießen
blamage für die bayern für die
holsteiner der wohl größte tage der
vereinsgeschichte seit der deutschen
meisterschaft 1912 gemeinsam jubeln im
freien trotz corona kiels sieg gegen die
übermacht aus bayern hat es möglich
gemacht haupt bewahrt zwingt die triple
sieger mit dem 2 2 in der nachspielzeit
ins elfmeterschießen
johannes delius hält gegen mark walker
und fin bartels lässt manuel neuer keine
chance
fertig ist der überraschungs sieg
natürlich waren die bayern überlegen
sind sie sind sie ja in fast jedem
spielen aber ich glaube was heute ganz
wichtig war dass wir einfach auch mutig
waren weil wir sind natürlich bedient
können sie sich vorstellen
ja auch das elfmeterschießen haben wir
relativ souverän absolviert aber kiel
hat halt auch gar keinen fehlschuss
gehabt die bayern scheinen nach mehr als
20 jahren wieder mal in der zweiten
runde aus holstein kiel kommt weiter als
gedacht
gegen den deutschen fußball bund gibt es
ein weiteres ermittlungsverfahren wegen
steuerhinterziehung die frankfurter
staatsanwaltschaft bestätigte dem zdf
dass es dabei um den verdacht der abgabe
unrichtige steuererklärungen und
steueranmeldung geht gegen den dfb läuft
bereits seit herbst 2020 ein ähnliches
verfahren ja auch noch eine personalie
nach zdf-informationen hat die deutsche
fußball liga dfb generalsekretär
friedrich kurz muss heute das vertrauen
in sie und will ihn von ihren sitzungen
auszuschließen
zur handball wm in ägypten morgen das
erste spiel der deutschen mannschaft der
gegner uruguay
die dhb auswahl ist klarer favorit
bundestrainer als regis lassen
jedenfalls fordert einen sieg von seinem
neu formierten team in reichweite der
pyramiden von gizeh lässt es sich an
frischer luft selbst in einer bubble
ganz gut aushalten die mitgereisten
nationalspieler um kapitän uwe
gensheimer wirken keineswegs besorgt
darüber nicht mit der bestmöglichen
auswahl vor ort zu sein
so ist das halt in zeiten der pandemie
wenn andere nicht mitmachen müssen halt
andere ran
[Musik]
ich denke da das ja da steht dies lasse
und glaubt daran dass sich seine
mannschaft von spiel zu spiel steigern
wird da trifft es sich ganz gut das
auftakt- gegner uruguay kein allzu
großes hindernis sein dürfte dass noch
etwas schnee sonst ruhiges winterwetter
sagt gleich katja horne vorher viertel
vor zehn freut sich christian sie was
auf sie im heute journal und wir freuen
uns wenn sie morgen wieder dabei sind
einen schönen abend wünsche ich ihn noch
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren viele von
ihnen freuen sich ja vielleicht über die
verschneite landschaft aber die hat auch
tücken denn in den bayrischen westlichen
alpen hat es jetzt so viel geschneit
dass dort die lawinengefahr gross stufe
vier von fünf dann können lawinen auch
spontan abgehen und auch jetzt in der
nacht schneit ist zwischen dem saarland
und dem alpenrand noch weiter und auch
über den nordosten deutschlands ziehen
noch einige schneeschauer an der donau
bildet sich heute nacht auch mal nebel
sonst bleibt die nacht trocken aber
überall kalt genug für glätte mit
tiefsttemperaturen oft im leichten bis
mäßigen frost und in bayern geht sogar
in den strengen frost runter mit minus 8
bis minus zehn grad die
höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen minus fünf und plus drei grad
es fällt aber kaum noch schnee höchstens
hier am erzgebirgskamm auch im thüringer
wald und im südlichen brandenburg kommt
noch etwas schnee herunter und im
schwarzwald gibt es noch letzte schauer
sonst wechseln sonne und wolken
freundlich miteinander ab und nach
ruhiger wird dann der samstag bei
temperaturen von minus sechs bis plus
zwei grad am sonntag dann aber kommen
von west neue schnee und schneeregen
wolken heran
dann wird es wieder sehr gefährlich
glatt auf den straßen und in der neuen
woche gibt es tauwetter schönen abend
noch